le sophisme comme voie de libération
intérieure
c'est à dire d'un autre de nos illusions
de nos de nos pulsions de nos de nos
tensions intérieures
mais je m'aperçois évidemment que
finalement le public sera large donc je
vais vraiment d'abord commencer par
mieux des films bien définir le soufisme
dans son principe et dans son histoire
et après on va entrer dans dans cette
intériorité du sujet
c'est à dire en quoi ça nous concerne
nous musulmans et non musulmans parce
que le soufisme propose des voies
d'accès à notre personnalité intérieur
hormis du cadre islamique et en cela
donc il est complètement en fête
universelle
même si la tâche est donc faite à
l'islam donc on essaie d'impliquer plus
le le public pour réellement qu'ils ont
manqué pour que chacun chacune en retire
quelque chose à l'issue de la de cette
rencontre